Harry Megan will and Kate making their
first official public appearance
together ladies and gentlemen this is
the Fab Four and we are spilling the
royalty hello royal obsessors i'm lauren
zima and this week harry megan will and
kate making their first official public
appearance all together at a royal
foundation event they spoke impact they
all made with heads together was
tremendous they joked as family do you
ever have disagreements about things and
rightfully so this first appearance is
being hailed as a major success the Fab
Four got a nickname and their
interactions gave royal obsessors a look
into intimate family dynamics while also
getting an important message about the
Royals advocacy work across plus these
adorable endearing moments oh my gosh
you guys we cannot stop looking at the
photos
well they cast any lingering fears we
might have had about how Megan's been
fitting into the royal family aside the
last thing you disagreed on how to
resolve it of course we know Harry
adores Megan we're a fantastic team we
know real but the whirlwind relationship
has meant that she didn't have much time
to get to know everyone we would really
by ourselves which I thought which was
crucial to me to make sure that we had a
chance to get to know each other from
care at a time when I literally didn't
tell anybody at all but look at how she
and Kate are laughing together listening
to each other
everyone's having so much fun so we're
spilling the royalty on this royal
family here's a deep dive into
everything we know about how Megan has
been bonding with each member of Harry's
kin anything I learned about him and his
family was what he would share with me
Harry has said the brother will was
longing to meet Megan well very slight
sits delighted Polly
as for Kate ABC News reports that megan
has quote a new ally and friend in the
Duchess that Kate has been helping guide
Megan through all of her transitions
into royal life remember Kate was a
commoner to she and will met in school
because I'm from the States you don't
grow up with the same understanding of
of the royal family and we can see how
Megan's Princess training is coming out
look how she's sitting at the Forum
hands folded legs crossed just like Kate
we've just been here for three months
and George and Charlotte aren't getting
a new aunt we know that Megan is
prioritizing getting close with the
little ones the Daily Mirror reports
that she has asked to babysit and she
broke royal protocol by being part of
the family's Christmas this year even
though she and Harry are not yet married
Megan and Harry stayed at Will and
Kate's country house so that they could
see George and Charlotte to open
presents on Christmas morning the
toddlers will also be in the wedding
four year old George as a pageboy
two year old Charlotte as a flower girl
our hearts are already melting then of
course there's the Queen and Prince
Phillip Megan first met Queen Elizabeth
in October / afternoon tea at Buckingham
Palace could there be anything more
British it's incredible
and this means everything even the
Queen's dogs approved 53 has been bought
up just laying on my feet during hey
even the family's pets opinions are
important plus as for Prince Philip well
we've learned that Harry is especially
close with his grandfather and Prince
Philip might even be part of the reason
that the wedding happened so fast
this is really well went by Royal
standards is because his 96 year old
grandfather the Duke of Edinburgh is is
retired now and Prince Harry really
wants him to be at this wedding he's
incredibly close to his grandfather and
being 96 Harry thought that it was it
was a great thing to get the wedding
sooner than later so his grandfather
could be there fit and healthy as for
his parents
Harry had this to say about Prince
Charles the family together have been
absolutely you know sort of support and
tugging at our heartstrings he said this
about what his mother Diana would have
thought because there's themes we are
loving all of the success Megan is
having in bonding with the royal family
and even sitting in that Duchess way I
want to be in alignment with royal
protocol you guys what did you think of
the Fab Four's first official public
appearance and do you like that nickname
let us know thanks so much for watching
i'm lauren zima cheerio
[Music]